[Music]
Tuesdays we were working on titanium
nage and we were talking about how you
know in the previous class with you that
we were working on this skill so it has
to be in here somewhere
well okay so at the end of class
Jonathan was asking Andrew that he's
feeling it in his shoulder when someone
is able to be projectable on that bottom
hand and was trying to project out in
this technique or the Vietnam or when
we're going on fully on into it and he
was asking you know what is he doing
wrong and so we were brainstorming he
wasn't well he was feeling it in his
shoulder he didn't give us drinks in the
group he felt like he was being
compromised somewhere and so we were
talking on the oh maybe we don't have
the right structure maybe we're not
rolling forward but we couldn't really
figure out what really was the route
so that's just standard odds a little
bit that we're not version of that
technique is on the hip
so you're not pushing through the arm
like we are today and so there's not
this there's not this movement so are
you doing this movement because a lot of
you do try to twist the arm over which
is in my opinion when it's a different
space-time you need to be in a different
place to do to cause the rotation
between these shoulder mechanism and the
head the one that we were doing for Oda
is the rotational the rotation is
occurring between the head and the hip
and so when it's when it's between the
head and the hip there is no really
inner deltoid there's no deltoid action
at all it's really might be a peck right
and then they're waiting for you or
you're waiting for you Ken and so the
kids already fallen when you get that
last thing over there so right so I
guess anytime that you feel a muscle
strain you want to look at it
of course I think that's what you're
trying to do here in terms of a muscle
isolation so meaning you don't have the
proper organization in your body for the
art and that can lead to that but you
also want to make sure that
you don't have these other things which
are your you've misunderstood two
versions and so you don't understand
which structure is actually being
utilized here so if I'm going to check a
structural consideration I have to make
sure that I understand what the
structure requirement is okay and then
then of course always you know if you
are having some sort of muscle bite and
muscle biting that muscle isolation
could very much be produced in a
beginner to intermediate by jidoka
because there's a great deal of weight
on it and so the temptation to push on
it is now be more encouraged and so they
will less likely hold structure they
will start deconstructing their body and
start focusing on whatever they can push
with and that might be your biceps and
your deltoids most of the time so yes
okay check if there if the if the
resistance can be lessened you see and
so I could see somebody not finding the
hip going to the arm in this version
when they should not be because they're
trying to hurry up and throw them
because they are in front of them and
they're trying to pull them to to be so
that they're behind them do you
understand so we kind of worked on that
over at the remainder of the week so
that the hookah is over to my buddy
going to my left and their way to my
right and you start going and now yeah
you look at you're doing that or as if
you just wait kind of like today's class
they're going to get in front of you you
just have to be patient and then it's
really just a love tap on the hip if you
want to look at all of those kind of
things really you know everything is
those kind of questions are going to be
answerable to a kinesiology : alysus and
then also to an architectural analysis
just like you know straight what is the
angle what the resistance are using
where's your fulcrum where's your how
long your lever all that kind of stuff
so with that also all of that holds true
now that I realized that it was a
tension our game with the stimulus arm
yeah yeah yeah on my last rep and I was
working with shadi wasn't
I realized I was moving a lot farther
away than the situation demanded leading
me to understand that I already had a
preconceived template that I was going
to operate under in which she didn't fit
into that they kind of screwed me up
what I was trying to figure out though
was in a situation like that because I
noticed you didn't have that problem
with Tristan or any other week it didn't
come in when you're trying to not
disengage from the contact is it is it
acceptable to just move forward if
necessary it could be that the problem
isn't whether you move forward or
backward right the problem is are you
matching right the voi - but are you
matching the yin to the young that's
that's the problem
and then the underlying problem to that
is you know the question of mismatching
that the underlying problem to
mismatching is are you stuck on yourself
are you are you just gonna do whatever
you do I always step back two feet every
time no matter who comes in no matter
how fast they come and I always just do
this or the problem might be
are you trying are you rejecting what
they're doing and so you're trying to
prevent them from from what they're
doing it's all a kind of non acceptance
right and so this is where you know Zen
and boutot and the formation of Buddha
that's where it happens because you can
you can sit here and I might be able to
in a coaching kind of way once you give
me a particular okay I can you know
paint out for you a diagram can you tell
them any questions a diagram on where
your foot should go at what time and at
what distance but then I'm only
correcting you for that particular range
of options that that you get does you
will not be able to take that diagram
and
move it over to a bigger or a larger or
a heavier or even a lighter or a less
skilled or a more afraid cooky it
doesn't happen so when the martial
artist you know somebody a long time ago
realized hey this is not really an
architectural problem this is a mind
problem this is a beam problem there's a
spirit problem it's it's beyond the the
gross lessons of you know angles and
fulcrums and that kind of stuff
so yeah I I can tell you all day you
know where to move where to move and
stuff can you have them wait please but
you won't get it until you are able to
address this other aspect of yourself
how am I getting in the way of this okay
so we in the training here at the dojo
we set the task for you we've given you
what is basically in a way a kind of
physical or moving : in the sense that
any kind of intellectual rationalization
is going to ultimately fail because you
will not be able to take that to the
next person do you understand and so
well then what does succeed I have to
feel it is the only it's the best way
that we describe it it's not perfect
you're not you if you you know the the
English were to feel that the verb to
feel it caps it captures many things but
it's the best way that we have of
expressing this it's not
anti-intellectual but it's not solved
intellectually okay so so you know in
our in our romance movies or maybe in
our own romances right you'll you'll
have you in your head and you
yeah you know but I ain't he doesn't he
doesn't even own a car and he lives in
his mom's basement and he's just trying
to be a YouTube star by playing video
games and everything in your head is
telling you hey drop that loser but your
heart is telling you but he's really
kind he's really caring he's there's a
nurturing to him and I'm just drawn to
it do you see and so when you go when
you go back now and you go you look at
that intellectually is it really is it
really intellectually invalid to be
drawn to somebody who is caring and
nurturing and sweet is it really
intellectually valid to be drawn to
someone who has the car lives in the
penthouse you know but is an is
that really no so so it's not that
feeling is is anti intellectual or
irrational it's just a different mode of
knowing what ends we say good knowing
right it's just a different a different
mode of relating to it to the world to
our environment to the situation's we
find ourselves in but we have to think
of feeling is different from my feelings
my emotions it's it's really another
form of sensory input that does capture
my emotions like sadness happiness and
things like that but also pressure I
feel pressure right there's there's a
pressure and if I have to go ahead and
calculate it to go Oh even oh there's
the pressure by the time you finish that
thought it's more than what you are
calculating do you see so I have to
establish this immediacy when I'm trying
to match for example here these Yin to
Jung this void to force relationships it
has to be a state
published not only harmoniously but
simultaneously and you cannot do that at
an intellectual level do you understand
you can only do it at what we described
as at a feeling level you can think of
it as if you want that the intellect you
know maybe the intellect travels at the
speed of light and maybe this what we're
calling feelings is able to travel it I
don't know warp beyond ten something
data made up right
remember your Star Trek so it goes even
faster and I would agree there is a
sense that it is able to travel faster
it is it does seem more immediate so
okay why do i do how do i what's getting
in the way of my training and
capitalizing upon the drills
well again do not prioritize the outside
external things so do not prioritize
chiton again I'm going to do oh we're
doing heightened Naga you think as
you're watching right oh we're doing
cartoon Naga then what happens you go
into your kite in nugget you see and
your kite and nugget always has a step
of two to four feet and and so you're
not you're not here to match do it do
you understand you and that becomes more
problematic when the drill itself isn't
really quite a key Horne Wazza it really
is just a yin and enya Union young in
your matching exercise do you understand
so I'm watching the class I am NOT going
to do chitin nage I don't even think
about chitin nage I just think okay how
do I not let that force push on my arm
at the grip how do I not let there
pizookie push on my Center at the
shukaku did you get that
and I'm just I'm basically the closest
you can get to it unfortunately or
fortunately is it's like dance I just
dance with the person again this is a
lost concept because everyone dances by
numbers nowadays and not by feeling or
touch and which is why you see videos
where you can change the music it
doesn't matter what the music is and why
you go to dance studios all over the
world and they are actually dancing
without music because you don't need the
music they have a count in a magic count
but it's not a feeling kind of thing I
get it's really gross to me can you task
Mary Jane with so that would be my first
step don't do the technique you think
we're doing stay in the moment make it
more like a dance they're pushing on you
right don't sit there and go I saw a lot
of you guys doing this next thing so the
next thing I wouldn't do is don't try to
transfer or predetermine your
architectural schemata don't don't do
that so you would go oh it's a person
without a hakama they're not going to
come in so then I won't go as far back I
how's that any more right than the other
that you're pulling the person with the
hakama you're not matching do you see
you're not in the moment you're not in
the present you're you're you're you're
trying to rationalize through this and
so you don't develop the skill of what
we call musubi or sensitivity and with
that comes write a whole lot of other
problems for example when we went to the
ballistic which wasn't very ballistic
but can you imagine if we made that a
very fast punch you're you're not going
to get anywhere with that but so even
with the slow push we were having
problems you know having them fall into
the void right or and that would become
amplified the further and further you
get away from
the finger hooks that we end up using
which is nothing more than I'm not
matching into young and so same thing
when you predetermine your course of
action because you look and you you
guess what they're Kimmie skill is going
to be that too is as wrong as saying at
the onset
oh it's cotton oh yeah I'm gonna do
cartoon nugget it's wrong because it's
not in the present do you guys
understand that and it not being in the
President and I'm not going to gain
these musubi and sensitivity skills and
I'm not going to be very Marshall in the
end I won't be very Marshall because we
already said that there's a kind of
speed or you know a kind of more
practical velocity to this sensitivity
overintellectualizing do you see so in
essence you've made yourself slower when
you try to do this mapping these pre
mapping so to speak in your
architectures and so oh I guess it'll
work if they're really slow and that
goes back to that whole problem your
Aikido shouldn't be only functionable or
functioning on slower weaker people okay
so that's how I would approach this and
you know especially like today's class
man give yourself some freedom to
experiment ok I I watch a lot of you you
you you start going and you're pulling
them and and you know you start going
like oh like someone else is pulling
them do you know how to be like you you
know you're pulling them you keep
pulling them you you can tell you're
pulling them and you start rejecting oh
man I can't believe I'm pulling them hey
when you okay when you wait where do you
feel that you're not holy then stop stop
and try to try one of the many other
angles right that this is a very strange
concept when you think about it but it
really did look like it so I always feel
like oh and hey hey can I talk to the
person who's doing the pulling because
it's not you you can see the mistake
like I can but you guys keep doing it so
you really go like okay do you know this
is not it right if I'm pulling if I'm
going from 12 to 6 and I can start to
feel a lot of tension as I'm moving
towards 6 o'clock
hey stop stop going towards 6 o'clock
try one of the other angles start with
the cardinal directions go to 3 let's
try it who cares right this what I mean
experiment go to 3 ok 3 are still a
little bit of pull all right go to 2:30
okay maybe I go ahead in my experiment
hey let's start again and let me see if
I was too late or let me see if I'm too
early right let me start connecting a
little bit more with you at ahead of
time really for these kind of classes
like this where we're really just trying
to develop the sensitivity and not any
kind of class curriculum or dojo
curriculum which we have nothing to do
with right we don't test in it we don't
give a about that we want the
skills so this is obviously a class that
we've done before we've done they're
related kihon before this week this is
clearly an experimental class so give
yourself the freedom to experiment stop
making the same mistakes and more
importantly stop yourself in the midst
of making a mistake you clearly know you
are give yourself the the room to go I'm
gonna go this way I'm gonna go that way
I'll go that way and see what I start
feeling okay was here something else yes
yeah who cares I don't know anything man
yeah you could go if sky 10 not yet but
right but you know part of me wants to
go and call it in Neal whole but I'm
sure there's some Japanese expert and
some code you you know Museum archivist
who's gonna go yeah you're gonna have a
cow but if you have coke you whole it's
a drill to develop coke you whole that's
what whole means and so in yeo-eun young
I'm doing in your in your hole right but
who do we have to name it am I better
now when I captured the name you know
it's see it I don't know it's also the
way like I I'm terrible I don't I don't
work with names
I don't work with faces either so you'd
have be surprised it like how many times
I might not remember your name because I
that's not you so the name of this
technique is not it's not that either
right it happens to me at work all the
time like I'll duck you know it's first
I should know they'll go you know you
know me I have my I don't know they'll
say or do something with you alright so
that's it to me give yourself your same
thing give yourself freedom to don't get
stuck on the names okay
every technique is really in your whole
every single technique is that okay just
like every single technique is kokyo
whole every every single technique is
that some sort of exercise meant to
cultivate some martial skill or
attribute that you could then go on to
use tactically not directly but in other
things right so there's going to be an
energy to someone who's drawing a weapon
on you right I said to seize they're
gonna be in or you'll incarnate
and so you're gonna match that and and
it doesn't matter which is why we have
weapons to a lot of people might go I
can't believe you guys are working with
firearms like I can't you see the anime
that I oh my god oh so I was like I drew
it or something I mean it was so funny
right um the anime is this this big huge
kind of you know jujitsu guys are gonna
attack this guy of the guy pulls up like
I don't know what that was like a less
lethal shot guy and shoots the character
and then the guy falls down even shoot
some books eyes on the ground I was just
too funny right so but even in modern
fighting you're not looking for a
one-to-one ratio between your
motivations or girls or your exercises
for skill development and your
applications there might be pieces here
or there but they're just a coincidence
of these other skills like in yo hole in
your matching or musubi or a cookie yoku
right it's not a one-to-one this just
like bench-pressing
is gonna make you stronger being
stronger is better in a fight than not
being stronger okay hey but you know
what don't sit there and tell the
attacker hey get on me get on my chest
and I'm gonna bench press you do you
understand so if the segue as ludicrous
as that idea would be you got to watch
your 1 to 1 and so when you don't have a
1 to 1 I drop that idea then the names
don't become important at all and they
might actually get in the way
thank each other please